hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
happy iPhone 8 launch day I feel like
every time there's an iPhone launch
something goes wrong I mess up my
pre-order i order the wrong phone I'm
traveling I'm out of town never fails
always something I'm not sure what it is
about my luck but this time I'm
traveling for a really fun project I've
only gone for a day which means tomorrow
I only back in town to get to my iPhone
but today is Friday and I filmed this a
few days ago and this is something that
I've been really looking forward to
checking out ever since I saw them at
the Apple event these are two of the new
wireless charging bases this one is by
Belkin and this one is by Mophie not
really sure which one I'm going to like
more since I got the gold iPhone 8 I got
the gold iPhone dock to go with it I was
trying to think what case would look
best and probably just gonna go back to
getting a white case but I thought I
would try out this this is the new pink
sand iPhone 8 case and I got the pinks
and Apple watch band to match of course
you got it back to the band with the
case fashion or something the first
thing no good unbox I guess is this
iPhone case leave it riveting unbox hold
on wait for it I love this color it's a
really really pretty sort of like a
blush pink I guess you could call it
sand pink that's what they're calling it
pink sand I'm wondering will this fit on
the iPhone 7 yes the iPhone 8 case fits
on the iPhone 7 seems like they made the
camera hole just a little bit smaller
this looks to me to be about the same
size so essentially I think this case is
basically the same so it's labeled on my
phone a case but you can obviously use
it for your iPhone 7 so that is good
news but in the meantime back you go
little boy let's open up this Apple
watch band see what this looks like on
here looks great yeah look at this
aesthetic I also get a question a lot
because when people look at my Apple
watch it looks like I'm wearing it
upside down but I haven't flipped
because I'm left-handed
newsflash most left-handers I know where
watches on the opposite hand the pink
sand on the white ceramic face
yeah this is beautiful I had such a
conflict on which Apple watch ticket I
wasn't sure if I wanted to get the gray
ceramic or the white ceramic or a 38
because this is the 42 and it's pretty
big so we'll see it's a very hard
decision I had a lot of conflicts I like
the bigger screen but I also feel like
my wrists are so small that a smaller
watch might look a little bit better I'm
not sure oh boy
so this is a gold dog let's open you up
this is a really nice gold color I'm
just hoping that all of these colors do
not clash I'm not a hundred percent in
love with it maybe like 73% actually in
this lighting I'm gonna go with like
maybe an 85 percent so let's just
picture this this is where the iPhone 8
will be tomorrow they might be late
upload but I will get an unboxing up for
you guys
I'm so excited I'm basically going to be
hopping off the plane at LAX with my
cardigan I'm a Nintendo switch and a
dream or is it my dream in a cardigan a
dream and coming on the plane and Miley
Cyrus party in the USA party in the USA
is Miley Cyrus that's what I said with
my Nintendo switch and my cardigan no
this isn't working out my hots up a
plane at LAX with that iPhone 8 in my
hand
Shh it's 11:30 1:00 p.m. it is very late
it's way past my bedtime this this is
the new Belkin wireless charging pad
classic Vulcan style that's a big it's a
very big pad so here you've got the
wireless charging pad disc maybe and and
here we've got this switch plugs right
into the wall
directions guess what you're not
supposed to do put your piece on the mat
this key is on the neck keys on the mat
literally I can't charge anything with
us yet except maybe Samsung phone no say
I'll say the look what you just
a little plate little I'm gonna falling
apart with right of your eyes it's got a
nice little group right here that shows
you're exactly for you to plug it in so
fits nicely to the ground so there won't
be any sort of raised cord when you set
it down on a flat surface there it is
is it on are you on yes
charging wirelessly the iPhone 8 and the
iPhone X both use qi wireless technology
so anything else that uses that as well
you will be able to charge on these
wireless pads max do you prefer mats
more pads
I feel like pads it has a a very
uncomfortable sound to it now let's
check out the Mophie wireless charging
base and I've used a bunch of the multi
wireless charging fingers in the past
there it is it seems to be almost the
same size maybe a little bit smaller oh
it's heavy
wait there's a size comparison I guess
at this point it really depends on what
color you want I feel like this is
definitely very smaller it has a much
lower profile a power cable just plugs
right into the back here this'll also be
a deciding factor of which port is
longer they seem to be same size so okay
good to know I know what you're saying
Wow oopsies oh but Justine Samsung's had
wireless charging forever but guess what
your messages are green not blue so
here's the Belkin and here is the Mophie
so I kind of think that I like the
Mojave sitting down it's very non
intrusive like I probably wouldn't even
know that that was something that you
could put your phone on to charge if I
didn't already know that that's what it
was
but this one's more like one of those
USB coffee cup warmers so you guys seen
those you plug it in you put your coffee
on it and it heats your coffee mug up I
mean as a size comparison look at this
it's like a little squished hockey puck
which one do you guys think that you
like more like you guys so much for
watching I hope you guys enjoyed this
quick little unboxing of the things that
I decided to get for my new iPhone 8 and
my new Apple watch I can't wait to try
this out with my new iPhone
stay tuned because all of my iPhone or
Apple watch videos will be out very very
shortly as soon as I can film and edit
them and post them online you guys will
be the first to know about it if you
aren't subscribed to my youtube channel
just hit the subscribe button
welcome to the family you can also hit
the little Bell button that's a little
notification so you will know exactly
what I post a video well that being said
I'm gonna go it is 11:30 p.m. and just
past my bedtime and I have a flight in
the morning and I have impact if you
guys have been subscribed for a while
you know this is nothing new and I'm
losing my voice and I'm drinking coffee
geez happy iPhone 8 launch day
[Music]